given how things are with ourselves and
the world one of the great questions we
face is should we love or should we cry
the history of philosophy has an
interesting take on the choice two of
the greatest thinkers of ancient Greece
were Democritus and Heraclitus both men
who lived to a very old age had a deep
knowledge of people and the world but
responded to what they knew in
strikingly different ways Heraclitus
couldn't stop weeping Democritus
couldn't stop laughing it's obvious why
Heraclitus cried once we open our eyes
fully to the reality of existence
it's a Spana sure you can ever carry on
there is simply so much to be said the
human animal is of the knighted deluded
uncontrolled and master perfectly
subjective meanness and suffering the
greater question is how and why one
would ever laugh there is of course
always the option of leap idiotic laugh
the plastic laugh of the sentimental
callous fool but this wasn't the
philosopher Democritus his way he
laughed richly and generously not
because some privileged position led him
to naively misunderstand how bad things
could be his good humor wasn't
delusional nor was it simply a random
quirk of temperament
Democritus laughed in a very particular
and highly admirable style because of
the way he thought about the world he
was a profound realist he knew
everything there is to know about the
human tendency to greed murder and lust
and about constant exposure to random
accident and misfortune but ultimately
Democritus was so convinced of the
darkness he knew so much about suffering
and risk he no longer felt he had to
register these constantly at the front
of his mind in order to do them justice
they seemed to him an entirely obvious
baseline fact about existence he could
be cheerful because anything nice sweet
or charming that came his way was
immediately experienced as a bonus a
gratifying addition to an originally
bleak starting point
by keeping the dark backdrop of life
always in mind
Democritus sharpened his appreciation of
whatever stood out against it a pleasant
thing that happened to him wasn't taken
to be a feeble compensation for his
larger dashed hopes it was a delightful
slightly improbable but very noteworthy
bucking of an always expected tragic
trend Democritus was known to have
enjoyed parties wine and drinking a life
without festivity is a long road without
an inn he wrote he didn't believe that
he had to feel constantly sad to prove
that he recognized life to be sad he
danced and drank because of her rightful
confidence that he had already done
justice and would in the future again
have to fully do justice to the sadness
of things Democritus was aiming at an
intelligent kind of cheerfulness one
that admits from the outset that life is
fundamentally grim but that uses this
despair as a catalyst for a more vivid
engagement with the beautiful kind
moments that do come one's way like an
English person who's especially adept at
drawing value from the last day of
summer or a condemned man who perfectly
save as the last meal before being led
to the firing squad Democritus was a
master practitioner of that highly
admirable state of mind
cheerful despair once we've acquired the
skill of cheerful despair life acquires
a distinctive new kind of sweetness in
all its pleasant stretches every
pain-free day is a blessing
we're amazed and touched on once in a
while someone seems to understand a few
things we say or does something
unexpectedly kind we enjoy the
distinctive cheerfulness of those who've
done all the crying they can and are
determined for a while at least to hold
on to the light
[Music]
you